dans la terre. C'est ce qu'on
fait à l'école Louis-Joseph
Papineau dans le quartier Saint-
Michel.
- A côté d'un batiment plutôt
austère, ce potager occupe
les élèves du programme E.A.U. :
Environnement et Agriculture
Urbaine.
GERMINA DOMINIQUE, élève
2e sec., Louis-Joseph-Papineau
- C'est pas moi qui a choisi,
c'est mes parents.
- Bien, finalement, comment
ça se passe?
- Ça se passe bien, c'est cool.
YAEL GALVAN-MENDOZA, élève,
2e sec., Louis-Joseph-Papineau
- Moi, je ne savais pas que
je m'embarquais la-dedans
et une fois dans le "mood",
c'était bien.
- La partie pratique semble
plaire aux élèves de 2e
secondaire.
JOSHUA DOUBLETTE, éleve
2e sec., Louis-Joseph-Papineau
- Ils ont dit : "On va plutôt
sortir dehors, aller prendre
l'air, faire pousser les légumes
et tout ca."
NAFISSA CHETTAB, élève
2e sec., Louis-Joseph-Papineau
- Ils ont dit que le cours
d'agriculture, c'était nouveau.
J'ai dit que je voulais essayer.
Je me suis dis que ca pouvait
changer de faire que des maths
- C'est la deuxième année que
l'école Louis-Joseph-Papineau
offre ce programme, comme
d'autres offrent du Sport-
Etudes.
- Je suis content parce que
ça nous apprend, ça nous
sensibilise sur la question
environnementale. C'est le fun
aussi de sortir et de cultiver.
MARIE BERENICE OUANDAOGO,
élève 2e sec., Louis-Joseph-Pap.
- On a chacun un jardin. On peut
ramener des affaires chez nous
qu'on a fait nous-mêmes,
pas industriel, et ça, c'est
vraiment "nice".
- Ces jardins que se partagent
plusieurs organismes
communautaires du quartier
St-Michel abritent aussi
les parcelles cultivées
par les élèves.
- À quoi ça sert? C'est comme
un petit rasoir, t'as raison.
T'as parfaitement raison.
- Ils sont guidés par une
enseignante de l'École
des métiers de l'horticulture
de Montréal.
FANNY DEBONNET, enseignante,
École des métiers horticulture
- Ils sont en équipes de deux
par parcelle. Et oui,
ils doivent s'en occuper depuis
la préparation, le semis,
le désherbage, l'entretien
et ensuite, les résultats sont
évalués à la fin de l'année
scolaire.
- Est-ce que je peux continuer
à faire ça? Non.
- Pour celle qui enseigne
l'aspect théorique du programme,
il faut cultiver la conscience
environnementale des jeunes.
CHRISTINE LANIESSE,
enseignante au programme E.A.U.
- C'est important de
sensibiliser les jeunes
à leur environnement. Qu'est-ce
que tu laisses comme empreinte,
mettons, quand t'achetes
une bouteille de plastique?
Qu'est-ce qu'elle devient?
- Est-ce que vous allez
réutiliser le sac après?
- C'est pour ça que le programme
est important. Comme une petite
graine pour la tomate, on plante
une petite graine dans
leur cerveau au niveau de
l'environnement, l'agriculture
urbaine puis ça fait des petits.
- Les enjeux écologiques sont
peut-être plus présents qu'avant
et l'agriculture urbaine plus
tendance. Cette école secondaire
a décidé de leur faire
une place de choix.
- L'agriculture urbaine,
l'écologie, l'environnement,
c'est tendance. Donc, même si
les premiers jours de classe,
c'est pas évident pour tout
le monde qu'on est dans un
programme qui est cool. Je pense
qu'avec le temps, ils vont
s'apercevoir qu'ils étaient
en avant-garde.
INES HADDAD, élève 2e sec.,
Louis-Joseph-Papineau
- Je viens de ramener du kale
et du piment.
- On va finir la récolte, et
ensuite on va remplir le cahier.
Comment on récolte le chou
frisé? C'est quelque chose qui
fascine plus d'un parce qu'ils
aiment ça. Donc, ils ont chacun
leur légume de prédilection, des
légumes qu'ils vont utiliser
davantage dans leur cuisine
avec leur famille.
- Et en commençant avec la
récolte, les jeunes voient
le fruit des efforts qu'il
faudra investir en planification
et en préparation pour que
le potager soit encore genereux
l'année suivante.
Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.